- People have a successful company
and they lose touch with the product.
When the time came to
germinate their ideas
they were ready and poised
and able to do that.
You could have put a chimpanzee
in Silicon Valley in 1986
and they would've been successful
in the venture business.
I don't have any of these
ornaments and plaques
that commemorate investments
or companies from yester-year.
I just think they're irrelevant.
There's really only one
thing that they care about,
and that care is deep.
Because starting a business,
founding a company,
is the hardest act in business.
Imagine if you're in your teens
and you become fascinated with something.
And nobody has, to best of my knowledge,
has ever addressed a graduating class
better than Steve did that day.
- He's a Welsh born venture capitalist
with Sequoia Capital in Silicon Valley.
He's a former member of the
board of directors of Google.
He has an estimated net-worth
of three billion dollars.
He's Michael Moritz,
and here's my take on his
top ten rules for success.
(woosh)
- People have a successful company
and they lose touch with the product
and making it very, very important
for the company,
just go back, and you know,
all this stuff that's been written
about Apple and Steve Jobs
in the last few months
is well worth reflecting on
because this was a man
who took over a company
that was essentially bankrupt in 1997
and he realized that the
products that this company
was selling were embarrassing,
they weren't doing
anything for the customer,
they weren't distinctive,
they weren't special,
they had nothing that captivated
the interest of the customer,
and for me, at Sequoia
Capital it starts with,
we're a research firm, not a product firm,
it starts with the service
that we're providing,
is it still relevant for our,
for our customers', you
know, entrepreneur's logic.
For a product's company,
I think people, they just
loose touch with the product.
I think it helps if, um,
you try and enter an environment
where you think you can learn a lot,
and whether that's inside an organization,
doesn't have to be a company,
it could be a, some other organization,
or, around people
that you particularly admire
that you could learn a lot from,
and, I think that just helps
expand one's horizons,
and also gives the individual a sense
of what excellence is really like,
if you picked the right setting
or the right set of individuals,
and done right, it's a
transformative set of experiences,
and massively expands your horizons,
and the sense that you
have all the wonderful
array of opportunities
that lie in front of you.
- What do you believe
set apart people like
Steve Jobs, and Mark
Zuckerburg, and Bill Gates.
- Apart from their character,
they happen to be in particular markets,
the personal computer market
for Steve Jobs and Bill Gates,
and the Internet for Mark Zuckerburg,
where they had spent their
youth and formative years,
assembling knowledge that,
and a deep interest in a particular topic
that the rest of the world
didn't know very much about,
so when the time came to
germinate their ideas,
they were ready and poised
and able to do that,
and obviously, then showed
their metal as entrepreneurs
because there were lots of other people
who were there at the same time,
but who subsequently failed,
whereas these people succeeded.
- What is your advice to a young person,
or not so young person,
who would like to become
a venture capitalist the way you did?
How should they go about doing it,
and should they do it?
- I think everybody should,
look it's,
there've been a few other people
who have been extremely
fortunate and lucky like I have,
and I think, you know, you
could've put a chimpanzee
in Silicon Valley in 1986
and they would've been successful
in the venture business.
(interviewer laughs)
And, um,
and, um, people just have
to follow their instincts
and try and do what they
think's going to excite them,
excite them everyday,
I think it's probably more fun,
more rewarding, more
demanding, more taxing,
to go and start a company.
- As opposed to being an investor?
- For sure.
I don't have any of these
ornaments and plaques
that commemorate investments
or companies from yester-year,
I just think they're irrelevant.
And it's about the past, and it's about,
I was at Hewlett Packard
the other day walking around
and they've got a museum,
which is very touching,
it's really interesting,
they've got all these old oscilloscopes
and computers and, and, and,
you know, these wonderful
calculators from 1971,
fascinating, they should
not be in the company
if you're thinking about tomorrow,
and they should be in a museum someplace
off campus, or off the premises,
and that's the way that I
think about our own business,
I think, and it's what I
was alluding to earlier,
I think if we don't stay
ahead of everybody else,
gradually, it's the story of every company
that began to go down,
unless you keep that fire up,
and keep worrying about losing tomorrow,
you'll never reap all
the wonders and benefits
that come from tomorrow,
which is why we try to,
obviously, you want to
learn from the past,
and not repeat the mistakes from the past,
but you never, from my point of view,
want to roll in relish, in past triumphs.
- [Female Interviewer] You read about
finding the people who are obsessed.
How do you determine if
somebody has an obsession.
- It's, um,
it's a good point and it's one that,
you know, I wrote about
with Alex in this book,
and I think it's a characteristic
of the most successful entrepreneurs
which is that they
certainly at the beginning
of their company, and often
for a very good long time,
are able to shut out
the rest of the world,
and just devote themselves
to what they're really
interested in doing, and shut
off all the other distractions
because there's really only
one thing that they care about
and that care is deep, and it's genuine,
and it's the sort of
thing that they go to bed,
you know, go to sleep thinking about,
and they wake up in the
morning, thinking about.
The best advice I ever got
was a set of three words,
which is follow your instincts.
By which I mean, if you've been
studying something at HQUST
that fascinates you enormously,
and you have an idea about
how you can build and create
something that maybe
just a little bit better
than what's on the market, go and do that,
and then see where it leads.
- I'm looking for your
reflections as a board member,
as an investor, is what you do,
what do you advice entrepreneurs to do
when things aren't working?
- I always think of it, and
people are always very skeptical
about this response, but
I always think about it
as if it's a very close family member
whose involved running the business,
it's somebody who has
worked incredibly hard,
because starting a business,
founding a company,
is the hardest act in business,
and people that haven't done
it don't really understand
how taxing it is, how demanding it is,
the emotional costs and
consequences, of it,
and, so, I always think gosh,
if this was a cousin, or
a sister, or a brother
running this business,
(heavy sigh)
do I think it's worth
them spending the next
period of their life, two or
three years of their life,
trying to salvage something,
from what seems like
an incredibly distressing situation.
And if the answer is
yes, then we're all in,
and if it's no, I will tell them that,
but invariably, and those
sorts of conversations
come around when you're thinking about
whether or not to sell a company,
you know whether the
most prudent thing to do
is to sell it, or not sell it,
and on the whole, we really, really
dislike selling companies,
but there are some situations
where you think gosh, the
way, that this person,
the best thing for them
is going to be to sell it
and then move on to something fresh,
and new and more promising.
Imagine if you're in your teens
and you become fascinated with something,
and you have that period
of time in your teens
and perhaps early twenties,
where you don't have distractions,
you don't have a job,
you don't have a family,
you don't have commitments,
and you can afford to
indulge your passion,
your passion can be
Bill Gates, circa 1973,
figuring out how to write
programing languages
for micro-computers, it could be
Steve Jobs and Steve Wozniak,
thinking about how to build
single board computers,
it could be Chad Hurley or Steve Chen,
the founders of YouTube,
trying to figure out how to
send video to one another,
it could be Max Levchin,
this incredibly wonderful
Ukrainian mathematician who was one of the
co-founders of PayPal,
trying to figure out how to move money
between mobile phones.
Well all of these people,
in their particular spheres
had thought a lot more
thought far more deeply
about that particular topic
than any of the rest of us,
they may not have known
a lot about other stuff,
they may not have known about how to read
a chart of accounts, or how
to think about marketing,
or how to set up international operations,
or how to build a logistics center,
but all of that stuff,
you can hire people to do that,
what you cannot hire people to do,
is to have the wonderful spark
and founding instinct and deep fascination
and abiding passion
for a particular topic.
Best advice that I could offer anybody is
to suggest that they go to YouTube
and watch a very touching,
moving, and affecting
address that Steve Jobs gave
several years before he died
to the students at Stanford University,
and nobody, to the best of my knowledge,
has ever addressed a graduating class
better than Steve did that day.
- Thank you so much for watching,
I made this video because
willyoulaugh asked me to,
so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do,
I'd also love to know
which of the top ten rules
had the biggest impact on you and why,
leave it in the comments,
I'll join in the discussion,
thank you so much for watching,
continue to believe,
and I'll see you soon.
(whoosh)